[Musique]
deux ans de négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux qui n'ont servi à
rien puisqu'ils sont dans la rue un
projet de loi mal ficelé dont le conseil
d'état lui même dit qu il ait ni fait ni
à faire le gouvernement il doit assumer
un îlot spa depuis le début ils n'osent
pas assumer pour moi c'est de
l'amateurisme
c'est la préparation et c'est
effectivement un texte à trous qui
montre que le gouvernement ne sait pas
où il veut aller
l'exercice il est impossible à partir du
moment où on sider que les retraites
c'est pas une question d'âge
nous parlementaires on nous dit vous
allez vous exprimer sur un projet de loi
mais par contre sur le financement on
verra plus tard
ce qu'on dit simplement c'est que le
système par points n'est pas un bon
système pour les français qui vaut mieux
garder le système par répartition par
trimestre elle qu'on a actuellement avec
une meilleure prise en compte grâce à
l'allongement de la durée de travail des
pénibilités non pas branche par branche
qu'on veut le faire le gouvernement mais
individu par individu
sanctionné par la médecine du travail on
se paye pardon une espèce de crise
d'honneur avec beaucoup de violence
sociale d'énervement presque une sorte
de dépression collective depuis bientôt
18 mois il ya eu d'abord la crise et
gilet jaune puis le mouvement social et
pendant ce temps là pardon mais la
france avance en marche arrière n'avait
pas besoin de faire tout ce pataquès bon
en réalité aboutir à cette jeune femme
milla a exercé complètement son droit à
la liberté d'expression je soutiens
milla et que nous devrions tous la
soutenir
bien sûr ces mots étaient violents et je
crois que dans une société on doit
pouvoir trouver d'autres expressions de
sa liberté que de dire du mal d'une
religion quelle qu'elle soit qui
représente en attachement pour des
milliers de croyants
ça ne change rien au fait que jamais
personne ne devrait être menacés pour
avoir tenu quelques discours que ce soit
fût-il d'ailleurs offensant en droit
français le blasphème
il n'est pas interdit on a le droit de
critiquer de manière extrêmement vive
même de manière impolie une religion
[Musique]